cyberpunk 2077's expansion has a new
release window and call of duty warzone
might be getting monsters
as a part of cd projekt's latest
earnings call the studio revealed that
cyberpunk 2077's highly anticipated
expansion will not arrive until sometime
in 2023 an official tweet concluded by
saying quote please stay tuned for more
details coming later this year i know
it's a bummer but look on the bright
side at least it's coming out in 2023
and not in 2077. the company also
revealed a whole list of what it's
working on for the rest of 2022 that
includes the recently delayed updated
version of witcher 3 the next witcher
game in unreal 5 support for gwent as
well as a spin-off to it more cyberpunk
support and development on an
unannounced project from the molasses
flood based on one of cd projekt's
franchises so with a new witcher game
already in development what do you think
the unannounced game could be the
molasses flood are responsible for drake
hollow and the flame in the flood so
maybe that can help steer your guesses
personally i'm a little shocked to see
the witcher monster slayer on this list
i assumed it wouldn't last too long but
i'm glad to see it'll stick around
longer because i haven't really gotten a
chance to play it much the game is
basically pokemon go but with swords
bombs and deadly monsters that cd
projekt earnings call also spoke about
earnings who knew cyberpunk 2077 has now
sold 18 million copies which is up from
13.7 million copies sold in the game's
first 21 days after launch in december
2020. the witcher 3 wild hunt meanwhile
has now sold 40 million copies the
entire witcher series has shifted 65
million plus units since the series
debuted in 2007 but the witcher isn't
the only game with monsters as call of
duty warzone might be getting some as
well activision released the first call
of duty season 3 teaser on april 13th
with a cinematic trailer to introduce
new operators and the classified arms
seasonal theme for vanguard and warzone
the trailer ended with the ferocious
roar of an unknown creature in the call
of duty twitter account has since added
a mysterious sound clip that continues
to point towards the season of monsters
just listening to the sound clip doesn't
provide an actual clue but youtuber
prestigious key has discovered a hidden
message by running the sound clip
through a spectrogram which provides a
visual voice print hidden in the audio
the spectrogram revealed season 3's
hidden message monsters are real having
towering monsters arrive in warzone
might seem a little outlandish but
leaguers previously claimed activision
had planned for a major event with
hollywood monsters such as godzilla and
king kong
twitter user b playing games even
replied to prestigious keys tweet adding
that the sound seems to be a match for
orca from 2019's godzilla king of
monsters call of duty's monstrous season
3 is scheduled to start on april 27th
now let's switch gears to a topic that
everyone loves free stuff from now until
april 21st at 8 a.m pacific time 11 a.m
eastern you can claim xcom 2 and
insurmountable on the epic game store
xcom 2 is one of the best tactic games
of all time it's set in a futuristic
world where aliens have control of earth
with brilliantly designed maps and
turn-based combat that test your wits
and forethought xcom 2 is a must play
game for all strategy fans
insurmountable is an interesting
roguelike that places you in the shoes
of a climber who scales monmouth
mountains in precarious weather and
conditions insurmountable has
choice-based gameplay mechanics that
make each run feel unique but alright
folks hit the comments section let me
know your eye color i'll see you
tomorrow